black friday shopping looked different
this year as many retailers adjusting
their plans to avoid large crowds as
would be there typically
eight news now reporter kate houston
shows us how some shoppers reacted to
the changes
instead of long lines and early crowds
many retailers saw a slower stream of
holiday shoppers this black friday
due to health and safety protocols
stores like the arsenal at city national
arena
only let a certain amount of shoppers in
at a time you have to keep your distance
but at the same time it makes you
excited for the future
when we get back to games and themes
we'll be able to look at things that we
took for granted and kind of appreciate
it more
to keep everyone in the holiday spirit
the arsenal brought in live music and
games for those that shopped in person
we just came out really to look for
anything and everything nothing in
particular
and why not i'm not going to live a
scared life
instead of doorbuster deals many big box
stores promoted online deals and offered
curbside pickup
shoppers that went in person say it was
calmer than in years past
normally we all started around four or
five in the morning and got up at eight
went to mcdonald's got cinnamon rolls
and everything like that
and here at 10 with ease due to the
financial hardships of covid19
the nevada retail association projects
sales at brick and mortar locations
will go down between three to eight
percent from last year
however analysts expect online sales
will help fill in that gap
kate houston 8 news now